what's going on reject nation I'm Greg
Alva now I'm John Humphrey so we're
going to watch the trailer for Professor
Marston and the wonder women and james
marsden meets Wonder Woman I'm excited
for this multiple women yeah multiple
it's not a one man they cloned her
future no it did Chris Marcin is the guy
I met is a polygraph invented Wonder
Woman it wasn't a Pollyanna murmurs
what's the word for a polyamorous
relationship with two women oh it's this
story okay yeah I've actually read
enough I'm assuming that's what this is
consuming consuming assuming who
professor Morrison is and that he did
all those things probably about the
relationship and stuff as well I
sometimes know a thing or two I can
guarantee you so many people click on
this thing and it's had something to do
with like a Wonder Woman sequel or so
it's comment sections must be going to
look for this later
is told hoping that is my pseudonym
why don't you write Wonder Woman under
your real name because most Americans
had a little painting of comic book
writers I listen to him
Lou Kevin annapurna i heard Wonder Woman
movie was coming out the person is most
happy when they are submissive to loving
Authority really gonna study her she'll
break your heart
Ruby Joseph I'm your wife Jacob Rebecca
Hawkman thank you longed for
unconventional life maybe I just won't
have because II do
[Music]
exclusively to keep it in time oh man I
[Music]
the world and stops is this what you
really want
dr. Marston every issue of Wonder Woman
filled with violence torture Sam Matthew
does Admiral behavior in their comic is
reckless a woman must not be told how to
use her freedom should find out for
herself if you want to have found one as
a woman you can start with that you lose
yours are hilarious ferocious you are my
life secret identity we're gonna have to
hide her true self of mansburg lonely
happiness Wonder Woman's secret identity
was reviewed Wow a whole calendar you
were the one with the secret identity
[Music]
Wow really cinematic dubstep Wow baby if
you're watching let's do this yeah let's
make one of these polyamorous get
polyamorous right so tell me what just
happened man it looks like it all turned
out very well for them and had no
dramatic implications whatsoever I know
some polyamorous people and it seems
like it works for them I've known some
people who've been in polyamorous
serious relationships and well it didn't
turn out well for them at all it was
actually quite horrible if you're
watching I imagine it would be quite
hard to do that I don't think it can't
work but I'd really very emotionally
confusing and my understanding so this
story's just about the luckiest guy in
the world
yeah uh-huh videos done fine Wonder
Woman created by a man I wonder if this
movie was greenlit when they heard about
the Wonder Woman movie coming out or if
they already had this in mind
that's a great question yeah because
this is an interesting topic for a movie
because it touches on a lot of different
things like it touches on wandering
which is you know hugely recognizable
but it also touches on you know a way of
life that is not fully understood right
now some might even consider a little
bit taboo yeah and yeah I'm really
curious as to how this came to me
because it looks like it's going to
touch a lot of subject matter and it's
going to kind of bring to light in some
regard life of these people it looks
emotionally heavy and it looks like an
erotic thriller at the same time and
also a period piece so there's a lot to
be intrigued by and look Evan you know I
mean how can you seem as Gaston and
beauty in the beams
perfect transition oh yeah yeah making
all those those dashing dashing wild and
Adams viewing them away down to a much
more subtle yeah it's just like that
song well we'll do a trailer review in a
separate video but you know because most
people are ready clicked off after the
reactions done this is just for random
two people who stuck around here or you
just woke up and forgot that you were
still watching subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram
go watch the Ruby